marry [ __ ] kill brad pitt matthew  mcconaughey or channing  tatum to be honest with you i want to  kill all three of them really yeah not  your type or you just hate it i just  hate everyone those are three not only  the more attractive those three the more  likable i feel like people they are they  well not matthew mcconaughey but i okay  no i want to kill him he annoys the [ __ ]  out of me i'd marry  brad pitt and i would [ __ ] channing  tatum those two are good i don't think i  could kill mcconaughey though oh my god  what is it you you're like you really  hate that's the one that's married to  the hot um  um hispanic one right yeah yeah i don't  like him it's the whole thing i'm not  into it